und zu unserem phoenix tagesgespräch
begrüße ich ganz herzlich heute den
af.de bundessprecher professor jörg
meuten professor nein wir sprechen
gleich ausführlich über ihre kritik die
sie natürlich am neuen konjunkturpaket
ganz sicher haben werden ich würde aber
gerne anders beginnen nämlich mit der
frage was hätten sie denn genau so
beschlossen also was finden sie gut
das ist ja ein sehr großes paket aus 57
einzelmaßnahmen da kann ich alles falsch
denn es sind gute dinge dabei also die
förderung der digitalisierung
unterstützen wir nachdrücklich das ist
ein sinnvoller schritt die unterstützung
des kommunalen sektors die zum teil in
bitterer not sind derzeit wegen
wegbrechender gewerbesteuereinnahmen
finden wir auch sehr gut und die
unterstützung kleiner mittlerer
unternehmen die in not sind wenn das
zielgerichtete förderung ist die
unterstützen wir auch da gibt es
durchaus sinnvolle maßnahmen das will
ich gar nicht in abrede stellen jetzt
kommt das große aber jetzt kommt das
aber denn insgesamt haben wir hier ein
paket mit unglaublich großen ausgaben
und wenig willkommen weil es wenig
zielgerichtet ist also nehmen sie
exemplarisch dass das herzstück des
pakets die mehrwertsteuersenkung auch da
sagen wir grundsätzlich ja die eine
senkung der steuern ist richtig auch
eine senkung der mehrwertsteuer ist
richtig aber es ist einfach stückwerk
das für sechs monate zu machen
das wird ein konjunkturprogramm für
finanzgerichte für finanzverwaltung für
steuerberater und buchhaltungssoftware
sonst wird das nichts wenn man sich mit
steuern etwas intensiver befasst hat ich
habe das von berufswegen mehrere
jahrzehnte getan
dann weiß man dass eine steuer
überwälzung an die verbraucher auf die
schnelle so gar nicht funktioniert und
es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich dass das in
preisen weitergegeben wird also nehmen
sie exemplarisch ein paar schuhe kostet
99 99 und jetzt würde das voll
weitergegeben wird 97 eur 38 kosten
glaubt irgendjemand dass die schuhe die
bislang 99 90 kostete ab dem ersten 74
97 38 gehandelt werden und zweite frage
dahinter würden die menschen dann die
schuhe kaufen für 97 38 wo sie bei 99
nein gesagt haben
das doch unwahrscheinlich und das ist
das leben dann bleiben wir bei diesem
rechenbeispiel sie fordern ja zwölf
prozent mehrwertsteuer also eine
deutlich größere senkung dann würde man
ein effekt erzielen da ist er dann auch
die frage kann so eine senkung überhaupt
die kauflaune heben vor allen dingen
sind wir der auffassung dass es
dauerhaft sein was eine temporäre
senkung ist völlig völlig hanebüchen die
ergibt keinen erkennbaren sinn
man braucht dann einen kräftigen schritt
damit ist immer noch nicht garantiert ob
diese letztlich kennen sie an tischen
nachfrage stimuli dann tatsächlich
wirken denn das problem das wir dass wir
derzeit haben ist die menschen haben
angst und man spricht dann unter
ökonomen auch von einer liquiditätsfalle
sie können den menschen die liquidität
geben damit es immer noch nicht
garantiert dass sie kaufen
ich denke und erlebe das selber tag für
tag wenn ich im einzelhandel einkaufe
dass zb die masken pflicht die aus
jetziger sicht mir überhaupt nicht mehr
notwendig erscheint die menschen massiv
vom kauf abhält
jeder ist froh wenn er im geschäft rein
geht dass er möglichst schnell wieder
draußen ist und so kommt kauflaune nicht
auf es ist auch die massive
verunsicherung in puncto mit 19 von
einer zweiten welle gesprochen von der
ganz ungewiss ist ob sie kommt und dann
betreiben die menschen angst sprachen
sie können sehen dass in unserem land
die die sparquote hoch gestiegen ist wie
noch nie zuvor
die nicht normalerweise bei 90 prozent
das lag sie auch im letzten jahr noch
die es jetzt auf über 16 prozent
gestiegen tendenz weiter steigend das
heißt es liegt gar nicht an der
kaufkraft das liegt daran dass die leute
aus vorsichtsgründen nicht mehr kaufen
und da muss man ansetzen
das heißt lassen sie uns noch einmal
weiter über die einzelnen punkte dieses
paket sprechen zum beispiel die senkung
der eeg-umlage die dürfte doch auch in
ihrem sinne sein auch wenn sie ja eine
abschaffung vielleicht besser gefunden
hätten
sie sagen es exakt wir halten die ganze
eeg-umlage für für moment erstmal so
salopp das eeg als solches ist eine
energiepolitische fehlentscheidung von
anfang an gewesen
hier ist eine abschaffung zu empfehlen
und nicht eine moderate senkung die dann
übrigens dadurch kompensiert wird dass
sie aus dem bundeshaushalt wieder
entschädigt wird sozusagen ja wer zahlt
in den bundeshaushalt
es hat auch nicht herr scholz sondern
nicht sagen die steuerzahler das heißt
sie geben in die eine tasche etwas mehr
rein und hole aus der anderen raus das
bringt nichts das ist flickschusterei
und das genau das was ihr mängeln und
die kritik an der regierung die gehört
er bekanntermaßen auch zu ihrem job
teilweise passte aber manchmal irgendwie
was nicht zusammen also jetzt sagen sie
zum beispiel merkels corona schatton hat
der wirtschaft schwer geschadet aber
naja professor morgen das war ihre idee
am 20 märz zum beispiel haben sie
getwittert wir brauchen den sofortigen
shutdown also wie passt das zusammen
nun wir alle wussten im märz nicht genau
wie entwickelt sich das und wenn sie
sich die zahlen von kogit 19 anschauen
aus dem märz dann waren wir genau in der
phase in einer phase exponentiellen
wachstums und wir konnten überhaupt
nicht wissen wie das weitergeht das gilt
für frau merkel wie für mich wie für
jeden anderen bürger und dann ist man
für vorsichtsmaßnahmen das einzige was
wir die regierung hier wirklich zum
vorwurf machen ist sie hat immer zu spät
gehandelt sie es zu spät in die in die
maßnahmen reingegangen und sie steigt
jetzt auch zu langsam aus was wir machen
ist nicht fundamental opposition sondern
wir machen konstruktive kritik ich habe
ihn ja auch gesagt dass nicht alles an
diesem paket falsch ist aber da wo wir
es aus guten gründen für falsch halten
da legen wir auch den finger in die
wunde und genauso ist es mit den co witt
maßnahmen auch da macht die regierung
sicherlich nicht alles verkehrt aber sie
handelt nicht entschlossen und dennoch
und sie handelt nicht schnell genug also
ich halte zum beispiel eine masken
pflicht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt für
völlig unsinnig und kontraproduktiv und
übrigens auch für einem anstieg der
nachfrage zuwider laufen
professor jörg neunten vielen dank für
das gespräch
ich danke ihnen schönen tag noch